tell me a little bit about the story
that you told us when you first came in
about how important Luke Cage is to you
personally well the thing is is that as
we well know there aren't a lot of
african-american superheroes and I've
been reading comics you know since I've
been eight nine years old and Luke Cage
stood out I mean not just because he was
black but also because he was funny he
was interesting he was strong and I
always felt a personal connection to the
character so of course when I heard that
you know Marvel and Netflix are doing a
show I put myself up for it and was
lucky enough to get a meeting with Jeff
and you know the rest is history but
that's the thing it's like even now even
though even though the you know the
character you know was found you came
out in 72 when I think about it and I
think about the impact of what's going
on right now like the world is ready for
a bulletproof black man
that scene you know that was written by
Kayla Cooper I mean it really
illustrates the tone of the show it's
like you know it's forward it's fun it's
hard you know it's got a 90s vibe but at
the same time is you know very much
today and you know I can't wait for you
guys see the rest of it Alfre like
obviously people send you things all the
time and I you know if you someone of
your statutes someone of your talent but
there was something about this material
that kind of just meant something to you
could you talk a little bit about that
well when I picked this up it was one of
the smartest piece of writing that I had
ever come across and that's what I do I
follow the script it's got it's got to
be there and so that's a attribute to
chose concept chose vision he carried it
all the way through it was it was set in
a place that I love and we'll all
probably talk about that the fact that
we all have numbers on the call sheet
but Harlem deserves a number on the call
sheet as well it is very much a
character and so we get all the cultural
importance the historical importance the
family everything that made Harlem what
it has been through the decades is there
it's there and then you've got you know
an incredible reluctant superhero and
you've got current turnover of what's
happening it's what's happening in
Harlem now it's something that's set in
the Marvel Universe but because the
Marvel Universe is so realistically
drawn you can feel like you can walk
right into Harlem and don't expect some
brother to be blocking bullets once you
get to Harlem but that's how well it was
done and I wanted to be a part of it I I
got excited reading it so I knew by the
time it stood up with all of these
really amazing actors and people who are
fun to hang out with I just wanted to be
invited to the party
I'm glad you invited me Jo a lot of
people talk about about the music how
did they tell us about
how music plays such a huge role in what
we're doing on this I mean it's not a
musical but it does have a what you and
I refer to a musicality yeah well that's
kind of what I call the wu-tang vacation
of the Marvel Universe meaning that it's
got attitude it's got flavor it's got a
grit but it's elegant at the same time
you know one of the things that was
really an influence was well first off
every single episode was named after a
different gangster song and the reason
for that is I wanted the 13 episodes to
feel almost like an album I mean it's
back in the day like when a prints
record came out or you know say for
example something like Ice Cube's death
certificate came out you would shut
things down and you would listen to the
entire record and so the only time we do
that nowadays I mean thanks to streaming
everything else is when you binge watch
it's like you just wanted it's the only
thing now beyond how records used to be
where you sit down and then there's a
rhythm everything is connected and so
that's really the thing about this show
in particular it's not just in terms of
the music and you know oddly show you
Muhammad and Adrian Young's incredible
score and you know and a lot of the
music that we have but also just in
terms of the pace I mean the way that
this thing fits together episodes 1
through 13 is relentless and man it's it
is what it is so Mike I think it's
pretty safe to say that the people
around the world fell in love with you
during Jessica Jones
earlier today we were talking about it
and and what's really interesting about
your character in Jessica Jones is is
that you really are seen through
Jessica's POV yeah there weren't Luke
Cage scenes there was a Luke Cage world
and so when and you knew when we started
out that there was going to be a Luke
eight show it wasn't like we planted a
spin-off and took it out it was this was
everybody knew that Luke and Jessica
have a thing and we wanted to be able to
show the thing but then we came to to do
in your show so when we're doing Marvis
with Kate tell us tell us different
about you know how you see your
character and and and the world that
you're living in when you come when the
story starts up again I think in you
know going back would you say to the POV
of Luke Cage through Jessica's eyes Luke
has his own problems and I think if you
watch Jessica Jones you know he's hiding
a lot of things in the closet and he
didn't care to find out too much about
what Jessica was hiding because he
didn't want to give too much away for
himself well eventually you find a lot
more information you start watching Luke
age the series that we're going to show
you on September 30th there's so much
backstory there's so many things that's
why when is the show on September 30th
September 30th only on Netflix you know
we have a lot of things in store for you
guys for the fanboys for the people who
just want to see some action we have
that for you a little romance I mean it
is like Jo said earlier it's a drama
first and foremost and it's set in a
superhero world and I'm so proud of what
we've done as a group and I can't wait
for you guys to see it tell us a little
bit about the complications of playing
Cornell Stokes Wow
it's just so it was a really exciting
experience to get to sit down and read
this first script because
it was I could hear the character and
for me that's always a good sign and I
could tell that he had depth and that he
was complicated
in his own way well intended but he was
just somebody who went about things in a
way that would that is probably
different from the common person
including myself so from day one it was
just this exploration that to kind of
always be digging to find the truth from
his point of view and it was just an
amazing journey
it really was it's an amazing
performance folks thank you vo we talked
a little bit about this earlier today
but you know hold on Jeff hey what
what's it what's it like trying to act
without your eyes I mean I it is it is a
I mean it may seem like a silly question
but to be in front of the camera and a
half to wear sunglasses most of the time
it is a real challenge isn't it yeah you
know it really it's crazy because when
this first came up you you know you
start seeing it and then you go wow you
never thought about it acting without
we're wearing sunglasses the whole time
you know how do you how do you do that
because everything's in your eyes
everything's in your face everything's
whatever so what's funny is my research
was daredevil because he's wearing
glasses and kind of never really looking
at anybody but so he was just you know
figuring out so that was kind of my
first reference point but um you know
you could feel it this whole world with
the characters with everything you feel
it in so many different ways and and the
glasses just make him way more shady
shady in all ways so it was pretty cool
it's cool to me but the shades himself
has has sort of a way of looking at the
world
kind of like a chess board doesn't hear
me at the end of the day it's about
trying to get what I think he's the
ultimate opportunist is the way I would
say you know he sees things in a very
different way he's always looking for a
way to move forward if he has to move
sideways a little to get forward he will
and whatever is gonna bring him to that
place
whatever train car he has to jump on he
will be naughty he's kind of the little
finger of Luke Cage so good it's good to
be four now see what happens next season
on that you Simone
Missy night is not an unknown character
but Missy night was an unknown character
to you when we offered you the part in
as Chell and I will will first attest
you came in you read you left we looked
at each other and said well that's done
we don't know really need to see anybody
else for this part
tell us about playing detective misty
Knight you know
when I first read the sides you know
Marvel is very secretive so they were
these dummy sides and I was like this is
dope like this woman it's funny she's
fiery she's a little bit you know bold
and brash and then of course none of
that was in the actual script but this
is this iconic woman who was so strong
and self-assured and determined and to
see that to see a woman who is her own
person she's not the wife she's not the
girlfriend she is not somebody's side
piece or sidekick she is absolutely her
own thing and for all of the misty night
fans out there you know this this show
gives you everything you want with her
and more like it's it's insane the stuff
that I would read when I would look at
the scripts every week and go oh my god
you guys want me to do this this is
insane thank you and then thanking God
at the same time because I'm like how
did they know that I knew how to do this
this is gonna be great so it was a gift
every single day and and when we meet
you you're actually undercover like we
don't even know that you are detective
misty nice no no Missy and her work
clothes when you first meet her Jo that
that portrait on the wall has a
particular significance to you can you
tell us a little bit about that picture
which everybody was screaming for it
just when they saw it well yeah well I
mean it's biggie you know I was
fortunate enough to know him as a
journalist back the day when when
writing the vibe I was one of the first
people interviewing and one of the last
people interview and that's the thing
was big he was such an incredible
storyteller with his rhymes but he also
like loved gangster movies so in a way
it was kind of an homage to him but at
the same time also kind of set the vibe
of the kind of character that you know
when big would tell those stories
cottonmouth
comes in to a certain extent from that
jicama tradition so you know it was just
a natural fit
and then plus I mean what Paul McGuigan
did in terms of framing that shot its
iconic
you